les nouvelles mesures contre le
coronavirus en israël également le
gouvernement enregistre les données des
personnes testées positivement aux
coronavirus à l'aide de la
géolocalisation sur leur téléphone les
autorités peuvent ainsi retracé le
parcours de ces personnes et ainsi
retrouver celles qu'elles ont pu
contaminer
selon paul a d'ailleurs journalistes rt
international cette mesure n'est pas
nouvelle mais c'est bien la première
fois qu'elle est utilisée par des
citoyens ordinaires
telle est simple analyse oui c'est un
moyen fréquemment utilisé par la
sécurité intérieure pour trouver des
extrémistes et des terroristes dans le
pays
et si vous demandez aux israéliens la
plupart d'entre eux soutiennent cette
mesure mais la réponse est différente si
vous leur demandez si cette mesure peut
être utilisée sur des citoyens
ordinaires
permettez moi de souligner qu israël
n'est pas le seul pays qui utilise cette
mesure en ce moment où l'iran et la
chine ont également utilisé est le
premier ministre a déclaré que cette
situation appelle à des mesures de
despotisme
il dit que c'est un moyen de lutter
contre le terrorisme pour la santé
publique
il appelle donc en fait la lutte contre
le coronavirus une lutte contre le
terrorisme et c'est ainsi qu'il se
justifie